hey guys
daniel rossen for the score Eastbourne
we've all seen it the kind of play that
blows your mind and makes you think how
the hell did they come up with that well
we wanted to celebrate the genius behind
some of the smartest plays in eSports
history so here are our top 10 200 IQ
plays across all of eSports kicking off
our list at number 10 is arguably the
biggest brain goal in rocket league in
history during the our LCS season 3
finals and our g-men tournament
favorites flipside tactics in the upper
bracket semi-final with the hopes of
advancing to the winners finals the
north american hopefuls pulled off one
of the greatest fates in the game with
garrett g slamming on the brakes causing
post defenders to hilariously fly past
them as they look for the ball
meanwhile cuts ear the rotating defender
is demoed by prior Byrne all in the
matter of a second flip sides defense is
dismantled letting Garrett literally put
the ball in the net
[Music]
[Applause]
at the number 9 spot on our list is a
play that makes Starcraft look all too
easy that's right
it's Scarlett's incredible baneling
detonation against bomber from Red Bull
battlegrounds 2013 after a tense two
games saw the series tied up at one
apiece
Scarlett took a bomber to a third map
and once that third map was nearly mined
out
Scarlett saw an opportunity and seized
it placing two banelings in the ground
near bombers bio army bomber had no
energy left to scan and with both
players armies jockeying for position
Scarlett faded the Korean with the left
there this could be a bomber can't
afford to scan so this Berto
deferral they're huge they're just over
to the right a little bit more bring
them out beta is trying to be
there's some Bailey cheer to reinforce
that would give you what a game head
starlet damn it
a stralla small tough play at IEM
Chicago 2018 was only a taste of the
brilliance today as showed during their
period of dominance which is why it
lands in the number eight spot on our
list down six rounds to fnatic in the
semi finals a straw has clawed their way
back to bring the game within one round
after losing the vise while trying to
take banana
astralis faked and a site push saving
just enough utility for be psyched mere
seconds later they pulled off the
perfect utility execute with quick work
the straw Louis took the site push the
game to ot and won the series this is an
early rotation out of him but this might
be what wins them the semi-final they
set it up so nicely the crowd is behind
them chuny let's go for Nats eight
thirty five seconds it's gonna be a lot
of Mallis all over the wall actually one
of them might land dead on Crim's this
could be the ticket for Australis these
grenades could do all of the work for
them three of them going over the wall
one of the cysts one on creams
everybody's catching fire
- on 4jw and pro-life left and they know
it as well JW trying to sleep JW Goes
Down and it's 15 15 overtime here the
semi finals coming in at the number 7
spot on our list is Canadian superstar
sure for who showed the world that you
can never relax on King's row don't
believe us well let over explain why
this 200 IQ big brain play is known as
the merry-go-round where are you going
oh this is so not cool chilly and small
so he's fighting you we could sort of
walk out what I'll try doing I think
he's gonna either and he's gonna either
switch to widow-makers
oh this the merry-go-round cuz that
makes me laugh speed up being short ball
switches to the Widowmaker just the
right time close it drops down today the
shooting range for Lane robits the
Canadian
sometimes the best laid plans file but
not this one coming into the number six
spot is the play that defined what a 200
IQ play meant in league of legends early
days that's right it's the expect during
I am cut a V say 2013 the League of
Legends community was treated to these
storied rivalry between fnatic and SK
gaming fnatic had their backs against
the wall in a last-ditch effort to end
the game
expect a used his Kassadin to sneak into
the base and take care of business
himself just gonna follow straight up to
all those super minions in the base you
can see is going in that is definitely
up called the Nexus he's trying to do it
the beta star has defended interface the
Nexus is
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
taking the number five spot on our list
is the decisions that gave oh gee
they're back to back TOS
otherwise known as the gyro diffusal
built during the International 9og were
once again making a run filled with
dominant and galaxy brain plays but it
was their gyro diffusal built on
Thompson that really put the world on
notice oh gee realized during the mid
game that no matter what they did they
simply couldn't deal with miracles
bristle back
so rather than simply wait it out until
the next game Thompson uses big brain to
buy it abusable essentially making
bristle back a giant sponge with no man
it's probably gonna be one of the
Ferengi to have said position that
aggressively look at that bill by
Thaksin diffusal gyrocopter quite one
defuse and I'm gonna join the fray
finally there we have it America's Man
it's pretty much entirely gone by toxins
folks to look to engage 88 these
technologies into the car by
they're even taunting they toss him to
the TRACON in 2013 we were treated to
one of the greatest TI finals in history
and the play that defined this series
takes a number 4 spot on our list yes
it's the million dollar dream coil in
the TI 3 grand finals both Alliance and
Navi were deadlocked the series went to
game 5 and at the 30 minute mark
na'vi were significantly ahead and
Alliance couldn't afford to take
teamfights in a last-ditch effort to win
Alliance win for a final push just as
na'vi were knocking on their door
seeing that alliance were getting far in
their base na'vi had to retreat to
defense that is until s4 laid down some
dream coils which stuns several Navi
members and cancelled their tepees
meaning that all Navi could do was sit
back and watch as Alliance destroyed
their hopes and dreams of a second TI
title they don't have enough damage
they don't have he canceled the beat
cookie Bobby's not gonna be back in the
face
he's gotta be kidding me but no boots of
travel
but it's fun now if they go over the
throne it could be game footage down
Alliance are doing it they need a little
more stuff all in jeopardy
that's a glyph it could be their last
stand
they wandered around they're gonna do it
with ti3
the L is just one 1.4 million dollars
during international strange happiness
at the number three spot we have the
ex-cons mark on csgo history
gambits run at the krakow major was
already defying expectations and their
final series against immortals was no
exception on the back of a losing round
gambit looked to be on their back foot
but doja and his big brain didn't back
down the Russian locked in a chi grenade
in the corner of a sight leaving steel
and lukas with such little health all
they could do was hear the bomb beep to
that nation their deaths left immortals
with such little money that gambit could
run away with the game the major and a
graffiti for good measure
immortals now feeling like they know
what to do two challenges banana
position the gambit has sent even more
firepower that's bring more cause it's
huge in the corner
blamed on Gosia with the don't that's so
smart that's one of the sickest I did
ever they plans in their faces and then
they both died that's so smart like this
is as well it up says that's incredible
during the 2016 world semi-finals pray
made his mark on a league of Legends
history which is why his legendary arrow
takes the runner-up spot on our list the
rocks Tigers had just lost the opener to
an absolute banger of a series and with
the opportunity to tie the series prey
fired a galaxy brain arrow that
single-handedly won his team the game
midlane alive because top and hip has
been killed and they even got the
pickoff on bank rocks doesn't actually
have to stop pushing right now they can
delay the recalls
[Applause]
stop
how much more can be done three kid
trying to burn it down
[Applause]
series
[Applause]
and forth and back again taking the top
spot on our list is a 200 IQ play that
you may not have noticed but still
leaves us for yup it's Ana's last second
item cell from TI 8 now this isn't the
first time you've seen this play top one
of our lists and we're about to remind
you why in the grand finals of TI a o G
were losing to PSG LGD battling and onna
had to farm to give the underdog some
semblance of a hope in the fight but he
was caught and rather than die for
nothing he sold some of his items so he
would have just enough money for buyback
to stay in the fight with honor being
able to stay alive oh gee were able to
take the fight to LGD and complete their
insane comeback it was arguably the
defining and most understated moment of
their miraculous Ti win these ancients
right now Ana FY just giving so much
information for the team he's got eyes
on him get the punch of the wrong target
for the snowball possible catch Ana Ana
he's in trouble the blood runs on is
correct he's got the magic back up in a
second but Kenny really plays way over
this one
until the Thompson Thompson being saved
by Derrick shags of the dinner I
returned to did whatever that the core
g kb boat he's trying to commit trying
to do about nine of you silenced by the
blow-dried but the ancient is warning
that Max is out there gonna be able to
find each other's 3d over G painting the
age
[Applause]
to a game by well that's our list you
think our 0iq brains missed a genius
play that had to be on their head us up
in the comments and let us know make
sure to LIKE and subscribe and we'll see
you next time thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]